ou que j'ai de la famille là-bas,
mais parce qu'un enfant de la campagne vit avec ce visage brillant et fabuleux.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
J'ai invité le public tswana à écouter l'histoire, mon histoire,
en tant que transgenre il y a des années, en anglais bien sûr,
car le tswana est une langue où il n'y a pas de genres
et ce qui s'en rapproche le plus est une approximation de « transgenre ».
Une importante partie de mon histoire a été omise dans cette histoire
par association plutôt que par honte.
« Kat » était une star internationale,
écrivaine de mode et sur le style de vie, musicienne, productrice de théâtre
et artiste --
toutes les choses qui me qualifient pour être une queer de la nouvelle ère,
traditionnelle, blanchie et digestible.
Kat.
Kat avait un diplôme de l'une des meilleures universités d'Afrique,
oh non, du monde.
Par association, ce que Kat n'était pas,
c'était comme les petits enfants à la peau brune
batifolant dans les rues d'un peuplement fortuit près d'une voie ferrée
comme Tati Siding
ou d'un village non officiel comme Kgagodi,
les jambes couvertes de chaussettes de poussière ;
les genoux noircis
après des années à genoux à cirer le plancher ;
les tibias marqués par les leçons apprises en montant aux arbres,
jouant jusqu'au crépuscule,
rentrant dîner à la lumière d'une lampe à pétrole
et retournant jouer à cache-cache au milieu des mille-pattes et des hiboux
jusqu'à ce que la mère de quelqu'un mette un terme à tout cela.
Tout cela a été perdu durant la traduction et la transition
et quand je l'ai réalisé,
j'ai décidé qu'il était temps de commencer à bâtir des ponts entre mes personnalités.
Pour que moi et les autres aient accès à moi,
j'ai commencé à indigéniser mon côté queer.
Ce que je veux dire par « indigéniser », c'est ôter le film de la vie en ville
qui vous empêche de voir la villageoise en moi.
A une époque où être noire, queer, africaine
et méritant de prendre de la place
signifie tout sauf venir de la campagne,
j'ai peur que nous effacions les difficultés
qui nous ont menés où nous sommes aujourd'hui.
La première fois où j'ai été queer dans un village,
j'avais la vingtaine et je portais un caftan.
Une partie de ma famille et des inconnus
se sont moqués du fait que je portais une robe.
Ma défense envers leurs commentaires était celle que ceux n'ayant pas de place,
ceux qui sont mieux que, apprennent :
nous les ignorons et disons : « Ils ne sont pas assez informés. »
Bien sûr, j'avais tort car mon idée de richesse de savoir
se basait sur le fait de s'extraire de la pensée et la vie du tiers monde.
Il m'a fallu du temps pour réaliser que mes actes de fierté
n'étaient pas les plus vivants dans ces grandes villes où je me baladais
mais dans les villages où je parlais les langues et jouais aux jeux,
où je me sentais chez moi et pouvais dire :
« J'ai vu le monde
et je sais que les gens comme moi ne sont pas seulement ici,
nous sommes partout. »
J'ai utilisé ces maisons de villages pour de l'introspection
et pour donner espoir aux autres n'ayant pas leur place.
Indigéniser mon côté queer,
c'est bâtir des ponts entre les nombreuses parties exceptionnelles de moi-même.
C'est honorer le fait
que ma langue peut se tordre pour parler les langues romanes
sans nier ou donner un caractère exotique au fait que quand je suis émue,
elle peut faire ceci :
(Hulule)
Cela veut dire --
(Cris)
(Applaudissements)
Cela signifie que marquer le bétail avec ma mère
ou couper du bois avec mes cousins
ne me rend pas moins fabuleuse ou queer,
même si je suis habituée aux soirées en terrasse,
aux menus accompagnés de vin et aux salons VIP.
(Rires)
Cela signifie porter ma fierté à travers la langue de ma grand-mère,
la nourriture de ma mère, la chanson de mon grand-père,
ma peau marquée par des histoires de chute du dos d'un âne
et d'années et d'années à dormir sous une couverture d'étoiles.
S'il y a un seul endroit où je n'ai pas ma place,
c'est dans un esprit où mon histoire commence avec la branche de mon côté queer
et non pas avec mes origines rurales.
Indigéniser mon côté queer, c'est comprendre
que le rural fait partie de moi et que j'en suis une partie indélébile.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)